il ya quelque chose que je voulais voir
avec vous savez je vous parle beaucoup
de smartphones d'actualité de
smartphones de guides d'achats tests
plein de produits plein plein plein il
ya des produits qui sont bien des
produits j'aime un peu moins bien mais
bon voilà yona pour tout à chacun
mais justement je voulais vous parler
d'un truc aujourd'hui je suis allé sur
un site un site qui est très connu un
site chinois qui vend des produits tech
mais pas que c'est oui et jalousie plein
de choses sur wii je ne te jamais
vraiment intéressé et je suis allé faire
un petit tour j'ai tapé dans la
recherche smartphones et j'ai halluciné
selon les choses sur lesquelles je suis
tombé et je trouve ça même dingue que ce
site est un orage aussi énorme pas
forcément toujours en terme de bonne
qualité mais là c'est juste dingue parce
qu'ils font fi de toutes les règles du
commerce ils vous vendent de la
contrefaçon il ya des choses qui sont
absolument hallucinante
je vous montre ça pour dénoncer ça pour
ça assez dingue c'est surtout vous dire
de ne pas aller acheter de smartphones
là bas et je vais vous montrer pourquoi
vous allez voir le truc c c'est juste
hallucinant on va taper sur wii on va
chercher smartphone vous allez voir il
ya plein plein de jolies choses premier
smartphone 70 euros alors que vous voyez
que le prix de base c'est 918 euros
je vois pas dans le commerce comme on
peut faire ça si ce n'est pas en
marquant n'importe quoi 2020 smartphone
huawei il n'y a pas comme une faute
d'orthographe là une lettre qui a été
oublié une vous marque si impétrantes
pétrole sorti l'année dernière paie 30
70 euros sur un peu de mal à y croire et
regarder à c'est là où on va tout le
truc de la contrefaçon il nous
réécrivons way différemment w à w le cpu
saint médiathèque 6595 excusez moi oui
n'y a pas de médiathèque elle est clean
donc on va déjà dès le départ que c'est
faux c'est archi-faux pourrait donc sur
une belle contrefaçon à 70 euros on va
continuer alors on a un p38 pro je
voudrais savoir qui fabrique sa 60 euros
au lieu de 550 euros mais bien sûr aux
intérêts comme ça messieurs dames
choisissez une taille je vois pas ce que
c'est que la taille là c'est pareil on
vous met un peu tout et n'importe quoi
ça c'est aussi une très jolie
contrefaçon à 60 euros
hélas si vous regardez les couleurs on
est dans les couleurs de au nord j'ai du
mal à comprendre que des sites comme ça
peut toujours exister parce que vous
êtes quand même sur un site chinois il
faut savoir que huawei c'est une
entreprise chinoise donc je sais pas
comment ils font pour laisser ce truc-là
exister jeu
- 97% le no à 6 62 euros au lieu de 2100
10 euros m'expliquer comment un
smartphone qui pourrait coûter vu la
tronche du smartphone solide avait coûté
2000 110 euros
en fait l'idée c'est que vous avez un
employé qui se dit battage de créer une
fiche à combien pourrait coûter suis à
comment je pourrais réussir à emmener
ces gens à venir acheter vos produits de
merde
eh bien je fais mettre un tarif hyper
haut ils ont l'impression d'avoir une
énorme remise alors que vous avez de la
merde
iverson auquel lui arrive à new ways six
drops screen vous avez une caméra à
l'arrière de 30 2 mégapixels à l'avant
16 mégapixels bon ok je passe un peu
l'histoire voilà bon rennes bien d'img
aurait dans une très très très belle
contrefaçon à ça ça m'intéresse sa
quantité limitée sur des iphone apple
iphone 10 s max 64 giga oenologue
ok ils nous mettent bien les photos
officielles d'apple là on voit le truc
posé sur un cahier à spirales je sais
pas c'est neuf c'est l'occasion où vous
mais regardez moi cette jolie boîte ça
c'est une très belle création donc
l'avion fabriqué une boîte donc la
bouffe on a très très belle contrefaçon
c'est complètement hallucinant
l'inde et la boîte vous avez déjà vu des
boîtes d'apple ressemble à ça on sait à
quoi ça ressemble une boîte d'apple ça
ressemble à tout sauf à ça grosse grosse
différence entre ces deux iphone
forcément on n'a pas le même gabarit et
il vous met quand même les photos
officielles en toute impunité à 311
autres à son or on n'est pas à 40 euros
ce qui sera déjà énorme vu que c'est de
la contrefaçon
non on est carrément à 311 euros on
doute de rien alors attendez il faut
mettre comment fiche technique laâyoune
absolument aucune donc là on vous fait
croire vous allez acheter un iphone 10 s
max alors qu'en fait vous allez acheter
une très belle contrefaçon à 300 euros
et c'est juste hallucinant à
regardez-moi ça là comme son idole mais
40 prône huawei nil 37 euros 65 euros
avec un médiathèque une fois de plus je
sais pas s'il ya des gens qui achètent
ça est-ce que vous avez déjà acheté un
truc comme ça vous est déjà tombé dans
le piège
moi je trouve ça fou fou que ces sites
et le droit de faire ça qu'on puisse
retrouver ses sites en toute impunité
sur le web qui vous vendent des
références qui vous font croire qu'ils
créent de toutes pièces des références
sont des marques ne faites pas croire
que huawei ne dépose pas le nom mais de
40 pro il a une marque de déposer
probablement en chine et bien évidemment
dans le reste du monde
pourquoi et comment ce site chinois fait
pour utiliser cette marque en toute
impunité en vendant sa dans le monde
entier
avec pratiques commerciales qui est faux
ce qui est trompeuse c'est absolument
incroyable et si vous continuez y en a
plein il ya des tonnes la regarder 800
repart devant 60 euros là on a quoi un f
33 pro 2200 s'il vous plaît 2233 on va
faire ça pour trouver quand même des
photos du constructeur officiel qui sont
détournés en toute impunité
il ya absolument aucun problème beats by
dr dre un même les écouteurs alors là on
continue dans le fin du fin je sais pas
je comprends pas la contrefaçon aux
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en
commentaires tels que je me trompe mais
la contrefaçon on est d'accord que ce
interne on n'a pas le droit de vendre de
la contrefaçon comment ce site fait pour
ne pas être interdite ne serait-ce qu'en
france ou dans n'importe quel pays
et puis d'autant plus que ça pourrait
être bloquée aux douanes c'est pas les
douanes fut trop quand même pas mal de
choses comment est ce qu'il laisse
entrer en france des produits vendus en
contrefaçon sur un site tapis nyon sur
rue et sur lequel vous pouvez venir vous
achetez votre contrefaçon ont toute
impunité
c'est voilà mystère et boule de gomme si
vous vous travaillons douanes ou si vous
connaissez quelqu'un qui travaille aux
douanes posez lui la question parce que
là pour moi c'est donc un loyer
on a tout plein de références ou encore
impétrantes pro prix phare à 64 euros et
si vous continuez à chercher là ses
smartphones et les smartphones choi a
smartphones samsung le est rendent plus
alors là ça n'existe pas le est rompu ce
n'est jamais sorti on a eu le samsung
galaxy s vendent plus on est le samsung
galaxy s 20 ultra mais le est ronde plus
donc là ils sont en avance dans le temps
il vous sortent le modèle de l'année
prochaine ah bah là et on regarde et on
veut bien marquer la zone
c'est une contrefaçon qui est assez
honteux alors si je vous parle de ça
c'est pas pour vous allez acheter dessus
c'est vraiment pour dénoncer ce système
est au contraire de ne pas aller acheter
sur ce site qui fait de la contrefaçon
je ne comprends pas que ce site est
encore pignon sur rue qu'on puisse le
voir en france je ne comprends pas qu'au
niveau de la législation il n'est pas
quelque chose qui soit fait pour venir
bloquer ça puisque on contrefaits des
marques et puisqu'on trompent le
consommateur donc trouve ça extrêmement
grave et j'ai beaucoup de mal à croire
qu'aujourd'hui ça ça soit accessible et
complices se faire livrer en toute
impunité en france un produit de sites
chinois
a vous de me dire vous ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire vous avez
déjà commandé sur ce site est-ce que
vous avez déjà comme l'un des
smartphones comme ça je vous démontrez
pas je le dirai pas mais ça vous est
déjà arrivé
moi ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire moi je constate une fois de
plus complètement hallucinant
sorcier vous donne rendez vous
extrêmement rapidement pour continuer à
parler tact à plein de choses qui
arrivent
on va parler de très belles choses pas
frauduleuses mais ça je voulais dénoncer
parce que je trouve ça extrêmement grave
norma l'amour incognito afin d'utiliser
les haqqani
[Musique]